tell me something boy buncha tired
trying to fill that boy quiet do you
need mom and it's hard keeping it's so
hard that mean that's he you just read
that now yeah really good I started
writing this song the other day maybe
that could work like as a chorus or
something I'm off the deep end
watch as I dive in I'll never meet the
ground crash through the surface where
they can't hurt us we're far from the
shell
Oh gotta tell you a secret I think you
might be a songwriter don't worry I
won't tell anybody but I'm not very good
at keeping secrets
but in
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe it's down litleo
[Music]
baby it's downloading
[Music]
takes luck to change
it takes a lot to try baby it's down a
little
[Music]
music is essentially 12 notes between
any of you 12 notes and the octave
repeats mr same story little over and
over all any artists can offer the world
here's how they seasons 12 notes if I
could take spirits from my best friend
the world
[Music]
you ready can I ask you a personal
question do you write songs or anything
I don't sing my own songs why I just I
just don't feel comfortable I want you
feel comfortable well cuz it's like
almost every single person that I've
come in contact with in the music
industry has told me that my nose is too
big and that I won't make it
your nose is beautiful you showing me
your nose right now you'd have to show -
you're looking at it all night oh come
on oh I'm gonna be thinking about your
nose we're probably set I love the truth
yeah your pose should I touch your nose
oh my gosh let me just touch it for a
second
Oh feel like I'm bad
[Music]
we were lucky oh really yeah not really
that my nose has not made me lucky
look talent comes everywhere but having
something to say and the way to say it
so people listen to it that's a whole
other bag unless you get out there and
you try to do it you'll never know
that's just the truth if there's one
reason we're supposed to be here is to
say something so people want to hear it
so you gotta grab it and you don't
apologize you don't worry about why
they're listening or how long they're
gonna be listening for you just tell
them what you want to say don't you
understand what I'm trying to tell you
yeah I don't like that I understand oh I
think you like it a little bit
[Music]
Jack I feel like we've done this before
the thing we do is so soon man come on
bro get up you know there's something
about when we started playing I always
knew like you were gonna do something
that you'd be alright
it's the first time I'm worried about
you
[Music]
maybe she's aware
you know it's like
I don't know you
you float out so what I to see and then
one day you find the port let me stay
here for a few days a few days it comes
a few years they forgot we were going in
the first place you realize you don't
really give a [ __ ] about we was going
because you like we yeah
[Music]
you
you